[Musica]
un saggio indiano si reca a milano a
trovare un amico
il giorno dopo i due passeggiano per la
città e all'improvviso all'indiano dice
ma lo senti questo grillo che canta e
l'amico dice no io non sento nulla ma
poi dai figurati se ci sono i grilli qui
ma l'indiano comincia a cercare tra le
foglie di un alberello striminzito
finché non trova il grillo canterino il
milanese per tutta risposta va beh voi
indiani si sa avete un udito più
sviluppato di noi bianchi no adesso sei
tu che ti sbagli dice l'amico e te lo
dimostro così prende una monetina la
lascia cadere a terra e all'improvviso
tutte le persone l'intorno si voltano a
guardare
hai visto dice l'indiano questa monetina
accadendo ha fatto un tintinnio più
fievole del canto del grillo eppure hai
notato quanti bianchi lo hanno udito
questa è una storiella tratta dal canto
del grillo di bruno ferrero e ci insegna
una cosa fondamentale cioè che per saper
ascoltare
non dobbiamo diventare tutti degli
indiani sioux ma che l'ascolto richiede
interesse volontà e aggiungo io
consapevolezza rispetto a quello che il
nostro ruolo nel mondo nella vita mi
occupo di natura lavoro all'interno di
un'oasi vvf in abruzzo
quindi un'area protetta ricca di habitat
di specie il mio ruolo è quello di
prendermi cura di questo patrimonio
ambientale
un ruolo che però mi porta
quotidianamente a dovermi confrontare
con tutte quelle realtà come
amministratori cacciatori sportivi
turisti studenti allevatori quindi
quelle realtà che condividono lo stesso
territorio e questo confronto mi ha
portato a maturare l'idea che sebbene in
questi ultimi vent'anni sicuramente nel
nostro paese l'attenzione la sensibilità
verso le tematiche ambientali aumentata
immagino che facciamo tutti la raccolta
differenziata a casa siamo attenti a
comprare il prodotto biologico quello a
basso impatto ambientale lì che ha la
certificazione sebbene tutto questo in
realtà siamo ancora alla preistoria
della presa di coscienza ambientale cosa
voglio dirvi il punto sta tutto nel come
ognuno di noi si rapporta con la natura
per alcuni questo è un elemento di
conflitto di competizione di ostacolo no
alla propria impresa la pall proprio
alla propria idea di sviluppo per altri
invece la natura è fonte di ispirazione
di piacere di svago
però se posso andare in montagna in
macchina sulla bella se tra sfaldata
piuttosto che sudare e faticare meglio
ancora
quindi in realtà noi abbiamo una visione
esclusivamente antropocentrica delle
questioni ambientali
abbiamo dimenticato che tutti gli esseri
viventi uomo compreso non vivono in
maniera isolata ma sono tutti parte
integranti di un grande ecosistema
chiamato terra ora nel corso della
nostra storia
l'umanità si è preoccupata ecco di
prelevare da questi sistemi naturali
tutte le risorse necessarie al
mantenimento della propria vita cibo
riparo energia vestiti noi non avremo
tutto questo se non ci fossero ad
esempio le piante che ci offrono le
fibre tessili con cui poi noi
impacchettiamo confezioniamo i nostri
indumenti non avremo cibo se non ci
fossero le api gli insetti impollinatori
che gratuitamente lavorano garantendoci
le produzioni agricole che arrivano
sulle nostre tavole e noi potremmo
citare tantissimi esempi di servizi che
la natura ci offre gratuitamente
ma badate bene l'ambiente non è un luogo
amorfo che circonda l'uomo no è un
sistema meraviglioso complesso è
continuamente in movimento e dinamico in
continua evoluzione e se la vita la
nostra vita
funziona è perché tutte le componenti
lavorano cooperano insieme per garantire
questa vita agosto 2016
io sono in montagna con la mia bella
attrezzatura ottica e all'improvviso
arriva l'alba che bello inizia a
scaldarmi e davanti ai miei occhi
compare una scena bellissima ci sono due
cuccioli di orso bruno marsicano che
stanno lì per più di un'ora a giocare
non troppo distanti da una mamma attenta
che li osserva
voi vi starete chiedendo ma adesso che
ci azzecca l'orso bruno marsicano
in tutto questo discorso e io vi dico ci
azzecca ci azzecca eccome chiaramente
non è stata quella la prima volta che ho
incontrato orsi nella mia vita ma
sicuramente quell'alba ha rappresentato
il mio canto del grillo il perché
scusate l'emozione ma l'orso bruno
marsicano
per me è una specie che rappresenta
molto è un po quello errante in cerca di
casa è un po quell'eroe no amato da
molti temuto odiato ostacolato ancora da
altri è sicuramente il simbolo di una
biodiversità continuamente minacciata ad
opera dell'uomo del degrado che opera
sulla natura lavorare con l'orso bruno
marsicano mi ha posto di fronte i nostri
limiti come esseri umani e soprattutto
guardare il mondo attraverso gli occhi
dell'orso mi ha insegnato che il nostro
punto di vista è imparziale e incompleto
ursus arctos marsicanus questo è il suo
nome scientifico si tratta di una specie
anzi una sottospecie differenziata
geneticamente dagli orsi bruni delle
alpi è un endemismo dell'italia centrale
significa che un orso unico al mondo e
ce l'abbiamo solo noi qui quindi pensate
che risorsa che ricchezza che patrimonio
che valore può avere questo animale oggi
la popolazione stimata in circa 50 60
individui e per questo motivo è stata
inserita all'interno della lista rossa
fra le specie a rischio di estinzione
la fragilità di questa specie dove
risiede risiede proprio nella sua
strategia evolutiva chiamata strategia k
a lento accrescimento
considerate che una femmina di orso
bruno marsicano diventa sessualmente
matura all'età di 4 anni può partorire
da uno a due cuccioli in casi
eccezionali 3 in casi unici come
avvenuto quest'anno con la nostra forza
marina 4 cuccioli e questi restano con
la madre fino almeno a due anni di vita
perché devono imparare tutti i segreti
per sopravvivere questo significa che
quella femmina non tornerà ad
accoppiarsi per almeno tre anni
ora se consideriamo il numero ridotto il
lento accrescimento e comunque gli
ostacoli che questi animali incontrano a
causa diretta o indiretta dell'uomo
dobbiamo sicuramente dire che questa è
una popolazione estremamente vitale che
ce la sta mettendo tutta per
sopravvivere
il 2019 è un anno che ci ha regalato una
speranza
abbiamo avuto 16 nascite magari non dice
molto ai non addetti al lavoro ai lavori
scusate ma vi assicuro che è un numero
forte e importante
finora questa popolazione è vissuta
all'interno dei territori del parco
nazionale d'abruzzo lazio e molise del
parco nazionale della majella e aree
limitrofe fra cui appunto la mia riserva
e qui per molti anni si è lavorato per
prendersi cura di questo animale
ad oggi però leggiamo la densità di
questa popolazione
all'interno di questi territori è
elevata un individuo adulto ha bisogno
di uno spazio vitale di almeno 80
chilometri quadrati
ora è come se ti chiedessi di vivere
insieme a 50 persone in venti metri
quadrati insomma si sarebbe veramente un
po stretti e allora perché questa
popolazione possa aumentare
numericamente siamo tutti concordi che
il futuro dell'orso bruno marsicano è
nella sua espansione verso nuovi
territori e questa espansione badate
bene già in atto perché in questi ultimi
anni raccogliamo sempre più dati di
specie di entrambi i sessi di individui
scusatemi di entrambi i sessi che
frequentano territori posti al di fuori
delle aree di storica frequentazione uno
studio universitario ci conferma che
l'italia dalla toscana all'umbria e al
lazio al molise alla campagna a le
condizioni ambientali idonee ad ospitare
250 orsi bruni marsicani quindi una
bella popolazione
allora che cosa dobbiamo fare il nostro
ruolo la nostra responsabilità ad ogni
livello
partendo dai singoli cittadini fino ai a
chi ha il governo del territorio è
proprio accompagnare questo processo di
espansione investendo in tutte quelle
misure necessarie a garantire la
sopravvivenza dell'orso bruno marsicano
nei suoi spostamenti ma anche a
prevenire il conflitto che si genera
quando uomo e orzo si incontrano
abbiamo lavorato tanto su questo vengono
distribuiti gratuitamente dei recenti
anti orso a tutte quelle attività
allevatori piccoli allevatori anche
produttori di colture di pregio proprio
per difendere il loro prodotto da
un'eventuale incursione adopera
dell'orso ma abbiamo anche potenziato
dove è stato possibile i corridoi
ecologici cioè dei passaggi utilizzati
in maniera preferenziale dalla fauna
selvatica per spostarsi da un modo
all'altro come seguendo degli accorgiamo
accorgimenti di road ecology quella
scienza che studia l'interazione fra la
natura
tra strutture viarie e quindi abbiamo
utilizzato proprio dei dissuasori ottici
e luminosi posti in punti strategici che
avvisano l'animale si presente sulla
carreggiata che un veicolo in
avvicinamento
in questo modo si evita l'impatto fra
veicolo e animale
il 2019 se da un lato ci ha regalato la
vita con queste nascite purtroppo
dall'altro ci ha portato anche episodi
di morte perché proprio a causa ecco
diciamo di investimenti che ancora
tardano ad essere realizzati sono state
perse e 2 femmine di orso bruno
marsicano investite su strada tre anni
fa abbiamo perso una femmina con due
cuccioli sono morti annegati in una
vasca raccolta costruita in montagna per
la raccolta delle acque piovane da
destinare al bestiame al pascolo una
vasca costruita senza sistemi di
protezione o sistemi di risalita
guardare queste morti
attraverso gli occhi dell'orso bruno
marsicano mi dice una cosa mi dice che
sicuramente molto abbiamo fatto che
questi sistemi di prevenzione servono e
bisogna ecco investire ma che di fatto
curano solo dei sintomi
c'è qualcosa che manca è questo parte da
ognuno di noi
un cambiamento culturale un cambiamento
di visione del mondo
un cambiamento io la chiamo rivoluzione
ecologica cioè sentire veramente dentro
di noi
questa il significato di questa parola
ecologia oikos vuol dire casa e allora
avere questa visione di camminare
insieme per condividere una casa comune
creare comunità a misura di orso
comunità misura dell'altro comunità a
misura del diverso questo non significa
che noi dobbiamo rinunciare al nostro
benessere no ma far sì che questo
avvenga in modo responsabile
sobrio durevole e soprattutto nei limiti
di un solo pianeta quello che abbiamo
terra e questo deve avvenire in maniera
equa per tutti non per una parte di
umanità ma per l'intera umanità per
tutte le forme di vita perché badate
bene tutto quello che noi viviamo la
deforestazione il cambiamento climatico
l'inquinamento degli oceani la perdita
di biodiversità ma la stessa emergenza
sanitaria che noi stiamo vivendo non
sono altro che la conseguenza del nostro
manomettere la natura del nostro volerla
possedere conquistare secondo un errato
concetto di consumo e libertà libertà
una parola bellissima una parola che
grida tutta la sua forza
e allora anche qui libertà attraverso
gli occhi dell'orso bruno marsicano
in abruzzo la convivenza con questo
animale
c'è da sempre quindi siamo abituati a
condividere i nostri territori con
l'orso soprattutto il lavoro che è stato
portato avanti dai tecnici della
conservazione dai tecnici della
comunicazione delle aree protette ma
anche dalle associazioni ambientaliste
ha sicuramente contribuito ad elevare il
livello di accettazione di questo
animale ma nonostante questo ancora oggi
noi ci ritroviamo orsi che vengono
uccisi avvelenati forse a cui si spara
orsi che scompaiono nel nulla e di cui
non sappiamo più niente
questo perché perché quello avvenuto a
mangiare le mie galline è dovuto a
mangiare i miei conigli i miei polli la
mia frutta le mie mele ecco che torna
sempre no il concetto dell'invasore che
viene ad invadere il mio spazio la mia
proprietà mimì depauperato delle mie
risorse quando ci va bene viene fuori il
classico ritornello prendetevi l'orso e
chiudetelo in un recinto e allora anche
qui recinto lo guarda attraverso gli
occhi dell'orso l'umanità ha sempre
costruito muri recenti ci abbiamo chiuso
dentro altri esseri umani
oggi permettiamo alla cultura dell'odio
di far leva sulle nostre paure sul
nostro istinto e il più delle volte
assistiamo indifferente a quelle
immagini che vengono trasmesse in tv di
persone che muoiono annegano nel mare
quindi di fronte a tutta questa
disgrazia a questo dramma della vita
probabilmente ti starai chiedendo ma
allora sephora figurati dai che importa
di chiudere un orso lupo in un recinto è
solo un orso è solo un lupo è solo un
immigrato io oggi sono mamma sono mamma
di due cuccioli domani saranno adulti
che cammineranno in questo mondo che io
gli sto preparando che tu gli stai
preparando la responsabilità che sento è
forte molto forte pesa e mi sono posta
una domanda e la pongo anche a te ma noi
possiamo davvero parlare di
sostenibilità ambientale
se prima non siamo pronti a quella
rivoluzione culturale di cui accennavo
prima
se prima noi dal basso ma anche i
governi dall'alto non sono pronti a
eliminare tutte quelle forme di libertà
come la povertà la mancanza di
assistenza sanitaria l'istruzione
noi possiamo parlare di sostenibilità
ambientale
se prima non parliamo di sostenibilità
della pace allora è questo che dobbiamo
insegnare ai nostri figli ai nostri
ragazzi nelle scuole a case da qui che
dobbiamo ripartire
se vogliamo uscire dall antropocene è
questo
badate bene prioritario molto più che
insegnare a riciclare plastica
riscoprire il senso di comunità e
possiamo farlo prendendoci cura delle
piccole cose io nel mio piccolo ci provo
con l'orso bruno marsicano con il lupo
con l'aquila reale ma voi potete uscire
da qui e prendervi cura di quel pezzetto
di marciapiede di fronte casa vostra che
condividete con il passante prendervi
cura del vostro vicino o di quella
sponda dice come dove vi piace andare a
passeggiare la domenica
riscopriamo questo senso di comunità e
vedrete che come dice christoph baker
solo in quel momento finalmente l'altro
il diverso il vecchio il bambino
l'orso il lupo gli uccelli pesci
sassi sarà soltanto un compagno di
viaggio in questo splendido spettacolo
che è la vita
[Applauso]